il est 14h30 à la poste marly le roy et
claude s'engage dans une tournée
particulière aujourd'hui il ne faudra
pas que distribuer le courrier à ses
clients il va aussi les prendre en photo
cela fait un an que claude est facteur
et pourtant comme beaucoup d'autres il
connaît déjà tous les habitants des rues
qu'il arpente quotidiennement alors face
à cette proximité yann arthus bertrand
et la poste ont invité tous les facteurs
de france a photographié les français
qui les touche dans le cadre de leur
tournée
claude n'a pas hésité à participer c'est
la première fois que l'on propose à des
facteurs de prendre effectivement un
appareil photo de pouvoir rentrer
quelque part dans cette intimité que la
plupart des français ne voient pas c'est
à dire de s'intéresser aux gens de les
prendre en photo et de leur poser des
questions et au delà du métier que nous
avons et que nous aimons c'est pour nous
un véritable panorama pour vous de
découvrir comment nous sommes au
quotidien toujours le sourire aux lèvres
il tire le portrait des différentes
personnes qu'ils rencontrent toutes
heureuses de se prêter au jeu l'occasion
aussi d'en apprendre un peu plus sur ces
visages qu'il côtoie quotidiennement
qu'est ce que tu aimerais voir changer
en france
c'est aussi la très large actuellement
au jour d'aujourd'hui ce que j'aimerais
voir
c'est plutôt une baisse de l'intolérance
mon facteur je le croise tous les jours
et donc c'est vraiment une relation
personnelle avec vif il me connaît on se
connaît la relation de proximité est
importante parce que on ne peut que
mieux servir son client quand on connait
je peux avoir des personnes qui ont des
recommandés avec des bonnes des
mauvaises nouvelles mais le facteur est
le facteur toujours souriante un lien
unique qui ni une profession humaines et
celles et ceux qu'ils inspirent ou les
me mets moi je suis facteur et tous mes
clients je les aime les photos
recueillies seront présentés à travers
une exposition digital d'ici la fin 2021
et les plus belles photos seront
exposées à la poste du louvre l'année
prochaine